in quel periodo stavamo girando un
cortometraggio e la mia amica e collega
il trucco scenico di un naso rotto il
programma di quella sera aveva anche
raffreddore o di durante le pause si
infilava dei pezzi di carta nel naso per
evitare che tutto colasse latente che le
veniva da starnuti ne è niente io ho
beccato uno sparuto probabilmente si
inseriva re questa cosa nel video al
legno di rapita è stata distrutta per
sempre però dovevo farlo l'eti ti voglio
bene qui a livelli siano fazzoletti che
cosa vuoi che cos'è secondo terzi di
carta ma che cosa poteva essere blocchi
dice di marmo ma perché ci aveva un po
di muco vede usciva dal naso una mamma
mia
guarda le t con questo veicolo ma non le
dà fastidio e cena fa da casterino dire
come ben vedere ma lo starnuto viene
causato dalla dal fazzoletto ma non lo
so stava male ma vogliamo chiamarlo a
questo punto chiede tini da morte e
miracoli di le ti guarda la pensa che
proprio è l'emblema di questa puntata
questa foto
ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di vita buttata il tema della
puntata di oggi è foto venute male
diciamo anche malissimo
quindi foto venute e malissimo
foto mostruose ho pensato di invitare
all'interno degli studios the casa mia è
una persona che dice ma non è che ha
avuto a che fare con foto brutte
sottoscritto cioè ci aprono avuto in 3d
niente popò di meno che mia mamma ciao
con la mano
questo segmento prontissima non ho preso
foto apposta anche perché ho delle foto
2 che sono abbastanza improponibili se
ce n'è un'altra improponibile secondo me
ecco la foto del tuo matrimonio a bema
l'ocarina mamma giovane e carina sim
avere una faccia al patibolo una donna
che veramente con 1 solo scatto che fa
passare la voglia di sposarsi per il
resto della tua inter esistenza sembra
sai qual è la foto di maria de filippi
che si sposa con costanzo devo dire non
ce lo hanno ri monio questa mamma mia
eravamo una festa di compleanno il tutto
in posa una mia amica
scatta la foto e il problema è che la
testa della ragazza al centro ha deciso
di non essere immortalata quindi adesso
delle con il reperto di tutti i ragazzi
sorridenti ne una che non sapremo mai se
stesse sorridendo mio perché qualcuno si
è portato via la sua faccia
ma tu migliori che non è chiusa dai non
ci posso credere assurdo c'è una faccia
ma soprattutto c'è quello che c'è dietro
la faccia capito sentendoci st l'unione
della spalla di lui con la spalla di
finanza o ci prendono in giro loro o se
non c'è da preoccuparsi che questi
ragazzi
prego ti prego ti prego ci facciamo
aiutare
chiesta e poi che se uno speri che abbia
questi sono i lasciti della felpa di una
fredda in capuzzo già pensare che cosa
che erano gli artigli di sapone che per
poco non è che mi ricordo granché di
questa foto come dan intuibile tuttavia
mi ricordo che per prendere quella
bottiglia d'acqua che nella foto tengo
stretta come se fosse la cosa più
importante del mondo
ho fatto praticamente una mezza capriola
in avanti però al rallentatore cioè non
sono morta o ancora il collo funzionante
è la mia migliore amica anziché
soccorrermi ha deciso di lasciarmi dieci
minuti così vedendo che emozione potessi
provare e ha ripreso il tutto
ecco cosa è successo alla ragazza della
foto prima le ha fatto questo e prendono
scatterà foto insieme agli altri
tutto qua risolto l'arcano possiamo
dormire tranquilli poiché carina sembra
gianmarco nemmeno giornata gianmarco con
della piccolo ere stime se il cielo o no
ma io non sto vedendo foto orribile
speriamo che arrivi qualche bel como
sono così sei contento allora qui
abbiamo delle proposte interessanti di
un pochino
ciao ciao ospite lo scenario questo
gardaland come puoi vedere siamo io e
mia cugina
ne abbiamo avuto la brillante idea di
stampa né queste foto
insomma spero che possano migliorare la
giornata ciao
stamattina una cugina sembra che bono
degli u2 o anche john lennon cioè quella
in cui stava pensando
ho lasciato tipo il gatto sul fuoco come
se non fosse partecipe di quello che sta
ma non avete si sta proprio divertente
maturata come una pazza
fammi vedere l'altra questa è la cosa
che stava dietro
amore da quando è sceso da quella lì a
quando siete su questa giostra 6 passati
40 anni
c'è quindi questa volta è stranota e
disse e della sala de cardona your le
ramaglie morire lei appello lei e la
taglia del peccato in questa rete ma
come fatto che non assomiglia per niente
a questa ragazza cui avesse carina
piccola precisazione io sono quelle che
ostacolino significhino con la quella
marittima spa righe insomma passare a
miglior vita
secondo me l'hanno accolta fine versa
con un sacco nero 6 soddisfare vendevano
ricominciamo essere io sono una foto per
esempio bruttissima era un po una balena
spiaggiata quindi c'era stata fotografia
di me sulla spiaggia che avevo già luigi
di pochi mesi orribile
ecco io quella non la faccio vedere non
la farei vedere chi oppure una foto che
non farei vedere mai martello poteri
nascosto me nero scattata io per genere
elfi allora allora piano
[Musica]
c'è mica sei tanto piccolo a riferirmi
c6 mamma sembra una differente questo è
il periodo dello sviluppo perché si
alterano i lineamenti in quella quella
di crescere narro scelta di shrek è sì è
vero è la mandai a pagan dirle ti prego
guarda che cosa è successo ti prego in
realtà lei mi ha detto perfetto qualcosa
per ricattarti per la tensione e quindi
lei tiene ancora questa foto che per
ricattarmi in modo di magari a una
pensione assicurata in futuro sperando
capito di potermi rovinare maledetta
affidarsi si era felice sulla sinistra
puoi vedere me vestita una lavatrice con
un costume home made e invece sulla
destra mia sorella travestita da dannatt
assassino probabilmente non aveva ancora
capito la differenza tra carnevale
halloween
dimmi che non ti spaventi resti sete la
vedesse spuntare da dietro un angolo
bellissimo ma che dovevano fare la
lavatrice dico che dovevo curarla dentro
la lavatrice vera asta ragazzina no ma
perché dorata ma così il carnevale no si
vede che lo è
mia madre è un rompipalle per quanto
riguarda i costumi perché veramente lei
quando era piccola non distingueva
halloween dal carnevale tua carnevale tv
stick it ha voglia con una testa in mano
no però quando mi sono vestita da boia
era giorno ragazza beh sì ci sta un
è il tipico vestito bene il ballo di 18
anni in volo ma non può essere lo stesso
la foto con mostrato al parrucchiere e
il risultato ho pagato in lacrime ho
cambiato parrucchiera tre anni ancora
richiamo di questa foto non è lei che ha
detto voglio questi capelli e questi
sono quelli che gli hanno fatto
ho capito che non è capito allora queste
sono due persone diverse e giusto mi
sembra evidente
ok dopo di che lei abbia mandato un
messaggio dov'eri quando io leggevo col
messaggio allora scusa un posto ogni tot
ogni tanto ma da quando sei arrivato
[Musica]
basta non parlo più non capisco perché
no no non lo so è perché in realtà
doveva venire un'altra persona che ha
avuto un buon ultimo io sono un ripido
mamma ma un fiume o se fosse per me non
ti chiamerai mai se potessi avevi detto
che gli oscar sono buca scherzo in
realtà volevo testa è certo perché lei
avrebbe fortificato bombe non so come né
perché so solo che stavo scendono la
discoteca mi annunciò che volevo una
foto intanto poverina sembra che gli
abbiano spezzato il collo
sembra che abbia capelli così lunghi che
la si sono tipo bloccati nel tavolo e
vino tutto ha inserito il 5 no piuttosto
grande ahmeti e di questa ragazza qui in
primo piano una mano
[Risate]
no non voglio che la gente pensa che io
volevo prendere in giro e allora stai
attenta in maniera deliziosa e discreta
a prendere in giro in maniera simpatica
con la bulla quale tu sei allora lui non
apprezza le foto con il flash di una
mano una rete bene ci stiamo soffermando
sulle letture degli amari nella gente
quello che ti mando è una delle foto
preferite e come puoi vedere rappresenta
un santino di gesù che mi tiene neonata
ed è capitata tra le mani è stata
realizzata completamente da mia nonna è
lei la tiene nel portafoglio e la mostra
con estremo orgoglio amici conoscenti
parenti chiunque niente quindi ecco mi è
capitata tra le mani le signore
fammi band ha la testa di me nipote luna
mettiamo in mano a gesù l'idea no se
quell'area l'idea fatta ma la pera olio
su tela analisi dell'opera un normale
pomeriggio trascorso in piscina ritrae
la mia migliore amica che in preda a un
apparentemente ingiustificato atto di
follia mi strappa la gopro dalle mani e
immortala questo scatto che è stato
nominato da noi la pena a casa nella
deformazione più credito che ha assunto
il suo volto terribile che è in faccia a
è sott'acqua ragazzi perché mi guardi a
me se parli di quello che siamo arrivati
alla fine di questo video ma noi ti
ringrazio perché ogni grazie a te tu
finisci sollevare le sai comunque anche
se sono un ripieno la donna grazie
davvero di cuore in realtà volevo che
sin dall'inizio
no vabbè scherza parere vi ringrazio
della prossima volta sarà la prima
scelta promesso un ripiego che dire io
ringrazio voi per aver seguito questo
video fino adesso come sempre vi chiede
farmi sapere quali sono state le vostre
esperienze con il tema di una puntata e
anche di farmi sapere magari secondo voi
quali potrebbero essere le puntate che
mi piacerebbe vedere in futuro
fatemelo sapere qua sotto
mamma infatti commentano con me
carnevale commentiamo tutti quanti
questo video con carnevale giornalai per
rendere felice mia madre per questa
puntata esilarante di carnevale ma
stiamo aspettando tutti quanti se volete
stare aggiornati su tutto quello che
postiamo iscrivetevi attivate la
notifica e banche basta presevo di
enrico pronto il record in a sbattergli
ieri un solo solo può chiudere il video
x me di vita buttata a pippo baudo
sicuramente il pippo baudo del web
grazie mille madre santa fe l'ha fatto
non si ok grazie goccia tutti è vero
scusa hai salutato
c'è però negato non ineducata